on se croirait dans n'importe quelle
stationnement à étages ou même dans un
quartier industriel anonyme
quatorze voitures peuvent se garer dans
l'ancienne imprimerie du toronto star
soudainement les lumières s'éteignent et
la pièce prend vie bienvenue à
l'exposition immersive bengo
[Musique]
les oeuvres s'anime la musique donne vie
à l'imaginaire du peintre néerlandais
[Applaudissements]
les voitures flottent dans cet espace
artistique
pas besoin d'aller loin pour voyager
téléphone à la main les visiteurs
s'assure de conserver des souvenirs les
plus jeunes eux ces merveilles
cette exposition d'art numérique est
présentée comme une première mondiale
qui taillé sur mesure pour l'an 2020 et
la part de nuit de coronavirus mettant
en vedette un peintre qui a souffert et
vécu de longs pans de sa vie en
isolement
c'est le co organisateur qu est ce qu a
eu l'idée ce printemps d'offrir cette
exposition en forme en service et lui
tous ceux qui veulent profiter de
l'expérience tel qu'il était prévu au
départ à pied peuvent aussi le faire
mais pandémie oblige il faut respecter
les cercles de distanciation
l'exposition rappelle celle présentée
cet hiver à montréal et à québec cet été
mais il s'agit d' équipe créatrice
différentes
à toronto la présentation était faite
sur mesure pour la pièce il donne
l'impression d'accompagner 20 ou dans
les derniers instants de sa vie alors
qu'il se remémore ce qu'il a vécu
retour dans la salle du service à l'auto
le spectacle de 35 minutes se termine
belle évasion pour certains d'autres
auraient plutôt aimait se promener à
pied au milieu des projections ça va
être intéressant de voir dans deux trois
ans après à la racine après tout ça
comment mais comment les expériences de
musées ou les expériences artistiques
ont changé et si ça va rester comme ça
leur embellie la vie est ainsi de la
réflexion mission réussie pour cette
exposition numérique qui se poursuit
jusqu'au 9 ou en voiture et jusqu'au 30
septembre pour le volet traditionnel ici
philippe leblanc radio canada toronto